les lazaret de la grande chaloupe choisi
pour sa situation encaissé isolé facile
à surveiller le site de la grande
chaloupe devient au milieu du dix
neuvième siècle un important lieu de
quarantaine des milliers d'engager venus
d'inde d'afrique de madagascar des
comores ou de chine
il séjourne avant d'être dirigés vers
les propriétés sucrières où les villes
de lazaret sont élevées de part et
d'autre de la ravine de la grande
chaloupe le premier construit dès 1860
le second est édifiée à partir de 1863
pour augmenter la capacité d'accueil en
quarantaine des immigrants il est
notamment constituée de deux dortoirs à
étages en maçonnerie désaffectée à
partir des années 1940 c'est de lazard
et sont peu à peu tomber en ruine le
lazaret numéro 1 a fait l'objet d'une
importante campagne de restauration au
début des années 2000 dumortier des gros
oeuvre obbadi gens de finition tous les
travaux ont été réalisés suivant les
techniques d'origine
longtemps seul lit sous la végétation et
les gravats
le petit cimetière à retrouver
l'essentiel de son espace d'origine
entourée d'un mur d'enceinte le quartier
d'isolement dernier bâtiment construit
en 1900 pour mettre en quarantaine les
immigrants le plus malade a lui aussi
été rénové il abrite aujourd'hui une
passionnante exposition consacrée à
l'histoire de ce site
lieu de mémoire majeur dans l'histoire
du peuplement de l'île
suite à la mobilisation des habitants
mais aussi d'associations et
d'historiens les lazaret de la grande
chaloupe en tête est classé monument
historique en 1998